and then I moved in with my dad and then
my mom jacked that car from me because I
went to the parking space
I'm like what the [__] where's the car I
called my mom you're not gonna believe
that someone stole the car show that
yeah I did I [__] came put a real
gangster now [__]
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us David so today what a Cheeto
fingers my Cheeto fingers baby guy uh oh
thank you wow it's very polite
um I'm a good host really
what was your first car and how did you
get it
Isuzu Trooper baby 4x4 let's go it's
just a dripper that's pretty giant I've
been trying to find that car again but
it's just like what year 1990 something
I don't remember which one but it was
before the the tire in the back had a
hard shell so it was it was a leather uh
the little case the first car we bought
or got and how'd you get it dude mine
was a a Honda Civic how'd you get it oh
my dad drove it he just gave it to me um
so he no stipulations nothing like him I
was working for the store so I had to go
drive back and forth for stuff but I
[__] loved that [__] car
dude like before Asus stopped creating
commercial uh like uh everyday vehicles
and they only went commercial because
that's where they started it anyways
that was like rated like the above the
Jeep the best 4x4 [__] four wheeler
at the time it was so [__] dope but I
just my dad we had it was just to fix it
cost so much because once they got rid
of their everyday car stuff they went
commercial getting parts you had to get
it from Japan and everything else so
just wasn't worth it yeah
it was a nice four screen dude I would
[__] like that now that's a great
first car actually I still I still love
this car I think it still looks great
it's [__] dope man hey that's a good
one uh I remember this one time because
I was uh just like every typical Asian
joke like age people can't drive it's
true with me I'm a terrible driver
everybody knows that about me uh I
remember I was I picked up this girl
that I was like had a crush on and then
we were talking I was like so mesmerized
by how hot she was uh I wasn't paying
attention and then I kind of let go of
the brakes and the cards started lean
for and I hit this old dude and he like
rolled on top of the hood oh [__] he had
like a walker and everything what he
went and I was wasn't even paying
attention this guy was like Hey
I'm like oh [__] and I stopped and he
just kindly got off because I didn't hit
him super hard oh okay yeah you were
just in his space yeah and I was like I
was like I'm so sorry and this guy was
so [__] understanding he just started
laughing old white guy oh
he was so kind though he just started
laughing because that thing happened to
him he's probably been through worse in
the war oh my God I was a nap this is
nothing
but yeah that was probably a little
little traumatized start taking the land
mine up yeah
it's like so specific I'm sorry
we can't see
it's just because you're tiny eyes
shout outs to old white guy Mike thank
you man you said you had a Civic I had
like a it was a hand-me-down name it
I think it was a 1989 Honda Civic oh wow
that's sick it had the automatic seat
belt is it though
[Music]
no way it's this thing that one yeah the
straight lines
it was something like it I think it was
it might have been the Honda Accord had
the automatic seat belt though I
remember I think it might first I tried
the 1990. because the Honda Accord with
the pop-up lights is the one that had
the automatic seat belt because I still
want that cartilage because we didn't
have the we didn't have the pop-up
lights no still pop up I think yeah
these are not pop up those are not
pop-up I think it was that that's crazy
your car was older than you yeah it was
because it was it was my it was my
grandma's car it was my dad's car and
then it was my sister's first couple
cars I still want this car and then I
was driving that I remember I was I was
like 15 and I was teaching myself how to
park
and just like I was just learning how to
park in the driveway and I backed it up
too far and I hit the [__] garage oh
no and I was like oh [__] and I didn't
have a license at the time but they
weren't like they were like dude what
the [__] are you doing they were like
mad at me don't you know you're Asian
what did they say but I was practicing
the time we tell you you're Asian what
do you mean I can't drive your insurance
is higher and you're also really really
smart but that was the car that was the
car and it's still because my dad was a
cigarette smoker so it smells like
cigarettes in there because oh and
didn't those have ashtrays in them yeah
yeah and it was like deep in the fabric
and I just remember like oh yeah dude
that smell is so nostalgic the cars
don't come with a cigarette lighter but
you have to buy it like separately for
when you punch it in oh and he used to
have like a little cigarette sign on it
that's right because there's a nothing
tab there now yeah right absolutely
nothing I miss smoking but I used to
love the smell of the cigarettes they
smell like it's this it's funny because
it is a nostalgic smell yeah because you
don't run anything
cigarettes in upholstery of things like
in Fabric and curtains good seats yeah
it smells like child abuse man mine was
uh 1986 Nissan 200 SX that's a really
dope first car bro
that's tight what color was it it was
two-toned it had a gray on bottom it
comes with the kit too like from Factory
wait you had this thing bro this car is
really that was what you had because I
wanted a uh I wanted a 86 Corolla still
[__] cool those are really cool is it
86 Corolla Initial D one yeah I wanted
that one but those are really expensive
and then that one looks like it it's
rear-wheel drive it's V6 it's hatchback
but it's a V6 so that's why I was like
yo I could hit people straight but I can
also drift baby that's a big that's a
big motor how'd you get this it was like
about a little over a grand and then at
what age 16 you bought it no I probably
was like 17. Wow 17 or eight how'd you
earn the money to buy it I just saved up
I've always made money since I was like
15 doing random things but mine was a
two-tone it was white on top gray on
bottom and that's not which Factory yeah
Factory and then the guy that I bought
it from
um he already had a couple cars it's
like this black dude and he was real
cool and he was all like I was like yeah
man
um when I was bargaining with them too I
was like yeah I'm gonna have to get like
get tuned and I need some money
um so I need I need to get it for like a
little bit cheaper and he goes yeah I
could see that you need some tunes and
I'm like huh and he goes yeah you want
to put some bass in like some tunes and
stuff and I'm like yeah no I think I'm
gonna get it tuned up and everything
like and I was like well I'll run with
it if you're gonna give it to me cheaper
but I remember it was like I saved so
much money up it was like a little over
a thousand bucks but back then it was
like I think thousand bucks would be
like 3K now yeah yeah even maybe even
more maybe more yeah but that's that
that took a minute to save but that was
my first purchase before that I had a
um when my pops left we had an extra car
so I was just using that one but that I
didn't feel like it was mine you know
right how long until you upgraded did
you drive this around for years or what
uh that one you know you're trying to be
like Initial D and [__] and then like me
and my buddies we were at this park in a
parking lot and then we heard uh police
signers in the back so we all just
[__] booked it and then
um my buddy got caught behind me and I
thought I got away and then my
transmission wouldn't go past like
second gear so I was like and I couldn't
go to third so the whole time like I
think I was going like 25 miles per hour
just home yeah and then like after that
it was done like you know I couldn't
afford just broken yeah and then so I
had this that Camry that that uh that
was kind of busted up for a minute and
then I saved up and I got a Supra a
1980. you had a Supra oh the MK3 I think
it was two
yeah it's 19
1989 that's awesome cool [__] man damn
Toyota Supra uh rest in peace my Honda
Element dude
it was a tagra top oh yeah yeah you had
a Target no no no sorry not tiger top it
was um it was in a it was in a you can
remove it yeah it does Target yeah okay
it wasn't it wasn't a convertible yeah
yeah it was Tiger top and then it was uh
this one is that one that exact one
remember that bar that's the Mark III
yeah and that's the one that burnt down
I have a picture of it too these things
are I actually have a I think I have a
picture in my phone of it burnt down my
dad had this exact same car now
everything about you is so cool I had
that wow you had two pop-up headlight
cars in a row yeah dude I really was
into Japanese Classics though well they
were Classics that much at the time
because I think this was still 2 000.
nice yeah oh the car right now dude I
see them on the streets bro and I'm like
always in [__] condition though man
people oh look at this that's my car oh
[__] isn't that crazy look
I tell the story all the time of like um
when I came home from Bart's house like
this I had smoke coming out of my garage
and my neighbor's like your garage is
smoking and I couldn't get in because I
already locked it it in the fire
department came they busted open and a
cloud of smoke came in and this [__] was
straight barbecue ribbing dude and
nothing else caught fire besides the car
it was a it looks electrical and then
the the fire guys just said it looked
like electrical from the headlight it
started there and then it spread
but it got destroyed man yeah and I
bought this from a [__] grandma in
San Diego how much like four grand four
or five yeah and those were uh stick huh
that was stick it was turbo yeah inline
six dude it's got a Crusher [__] yeah
man I know man and then the thing that
beats me up though is I've never had
cars that I full fully finished project
wise even till this day so all the cards
that I bought it was always like I had a
dream of what it was gonna be and then
it broke down right so like even right
now like
um I you know I have my Tacoma I haven't
finished it and then like I have what's
not finished with the Tacoma uh well I
wanna do like a lift and I want to get
new wheels and everything and I want to
get like a and Land Cruisers mainly
cosmetic huh Land Cruiser is one of
those things where I think I love it now
just the way it is but eventually as
time goes I'll probably convert it
yeah
but I do miss those old cars man those
are really fun what about you Anthony
what was your first car dude nothing's
as cool as everything Joe just said I
feel so weak but I've never had Civics
and integras and I always wanted them
these were a result of I couldn't afford
those so I got the coolest thing that I
can afford I I never had my own car
until like way late so like I I my
parents had a dry cleaners so I like
learned on my parents delivery van which
is a 1982 Volkswagen van again
and then and then just turns on a dry
cleaner yeah [__] biting much
hey why don't you come over here you
[__] hungry you want to talk to me on
my face dry cleaners why are you biting
bro
at the end of the day it was [__]
oppression Olympics right now yeah dude
yeah what else did your parents also
beat you what was the car that you were
watching beat me off what was the car
that you were allowed to drive oh you're
white so I was I was driving that which
one the 1982 Volkswagen van again oh
that's right no you are steering that is
[__] cool of mannequin when you're
really young you're not thinking about
things in that way yet I guess and uh no
it didn't have a pop top but they and uh
uh it was Twinkie mobile so it was like
uh both two-toned like dark brown light
brown right there isn't that the Ninja
Turtle van it's literally this one huh
oh no yeah I thought that's my dream van
I want that one when you're I want the
boxy one 14 15 you're not really oh it
wasn't cool that no way yeah and it
wasn't like decked out it was like we
they took out the middle seat because we
had to pull in other people's dry
cleaning and deliver clothes so we had
to put in metal bars yeah yeah yeah I
mean so so I learned on that one and
then one of our um our pressers for like
the shirts this old old ass Vietnamese
guy right he had a 1990 Toyota Camry it
was like this bluish silver one that we
bought off of him so I think like 2 500
bucks and that was the one me and my
sister actually drove around oh and then
finally she got a 2002 this type yeah
yeah that's super Vietnamese and then
she got it she got a 2002 Honda Civic DX
and when she 2000 2002. when she
graduated four-door white uh a white
sedan
graduate high school that was finally
when I was driving one car by myself not
sharing it with us 2002 was where you
finally were the four-door sedan DX not
cool at all what color was that white
White's nice stock as [__]
but my first time I ever bought my own
car for myself wasn't until I got a 2006
uh Honda Accord Coupe black stick shift
oh that's pretty cool dude see I never
owned a Honda and I thought they were so
cool yeah I bought that one for myself
wow but were your guys's height just
these ones huh yeah but it was like it
had like a lip kit on it oh you hooked
it up I bought it uh no no I bought it
used I think that's when I first met you
when you had that yeah I had that car
yeah what was your guys's like high
school like oh does the car need to get
Integra man in high school Integra
everybody wanted an Integra mine was a
Jeep Grand Cherokee I was always so
weird compared to my friends I always
like to lift the trucks and stuff oh you
had a Jeep Grand Cherokee no no that was
my dream car like all my friends wanted
Integra Civic SI whatever all that stuff
we're gonna put a B16 or whatever yeah
yeah and then for me I was like I always
just liked trucks and jeeps and [__]
like that truck guys four runners yeah I
always just like those and would you get
stuck with driving that time so my first
car was a 90s Volvo station wagon it was
like a burgundy one look up like 95. I
probably weigh like three tons
super Very Superstitious so she she
thought I was always gonna just crash
into something so she's like let me get
this [__] a tank
so that was like and then she likes the
color red because it's supposed to be
lucky so she spent like five G's and she
got me a a state
like that older than that older than
that yeah and then she got me a station
wagon like that but what was cool I got
to make the best out of that when she
got me that car I don't really have no
we got these these
but I'm like what the churches always
gave these away to somebody I'm like
there's no that's not cool at all right
there's no way I can [__] go like hit
people up at the [__] movie theaters
but I was able to uh turn like lemons
into lemonade because I was like the
back was actually really comfy so I
ended up putting like sleeping bags and
[__] back there so I was able to kind of
go also be a cool place just hang out
like if we ever [__] yeah dude I never
[__] back there but just to go like
hang out and like open the door one of
those boys yo if you if you I could kind
of Imagine That lifted though
that might be
so that thing was so old I don't even if
it's real that day was so old it died in
under a year oh [__] and so my mom ended
up getting a new a car a CRV so she gave
me hers
so type in maybe like I don't know tooth
here here it is here it is lifted
hey there's your Jeep Grand Cherokee
dream and it's like a Subaru I've been
I don't know maybe like 1998 Honda CRV
or some [__] or two thousand
eight oh these babies these cars are so
resilient you still see these guys
oh though yeah and then my mom was
[__] being a spying ass [__] so this
is when I got kicked out of my my uh my
high schools no personal responsibility
whatsoever this was like let's go super
stupid she got this card anyone made me
sick because like she think I'm
dangerous but yeah no [__] dude she
caught you that goddamn car and then I
moved in with my dad and then my mom
jacked that car from me so I went to the
parking space I'm like what the [__]
where's the car I called my mom we're
not gonna believe that someone stole the
car so that yeah I did I [__] came
who the real gangster now [__]
she would go every week and look at the
uh odometer to see how much I drove and
that was during like the uh
oh what's the [__] Raven [__] San
Bernardino Master Dome Master Dome days
yeah yeah Master Dome days so [__]
every week I'm driving probably A
Thousand Miles wow
everywhere you know what I mean I'll
spend like a thousand miles a week
Vanessa Carlton chill yeah she's like
you're driving way too much so she came
jacked it how come you never thought
about her catching you
well she lived in Cerritos my dad lives
I didn't know she was gonna come just to
look at the odometer that is pretty uh
intense man yeah [__] peekaboo I feel
like that's Asian parents to the tea
though like my parents didn't want me to
watch TV so they would check the the
back of the TV series yeah yeah and if
it was any like a degree off they would
beat my ass dude yeah close watching PBS
I was learning and then the first car I
bought myself because I started selling
drugs it was a 95 Civic EX oh that's
nice
once you get a Honda you know you made
it wait does that mean you but you
didn't buy it uh oh it couldn't have
been brand new no it wasn't new the
thing that I learned though I bought it
from one of those you don't know on like
on Garvey there's about a billion used
car dealerships what color was yours
black so I didn't know much about cars
that baby right there yeah I was so
excited to get one I brought it over to
one of my homies that stole cars and the
minute he started so much worse the
minute he popped the hood open he goes
oh dude this thing's salvaged like a
[__] he's like this thing's
probably not even worth like two grand
oh no cause you could just tell oh
that's from the radiator from a junkyard
but because like you know what something
gets received by a junkyard don't mark
it with like chalk or something yeah so
don't Mark things up but he could tell
oh that's from a junk cars this like
this car was just Frankenstein together
and I was like oh [__] I didn't [__]
know how much you dropped on it I can't
spend like probably like another like
five G's dad that fool took you for a
while yeah so I overpaid by like three
grand yeah
but then I had good memories in that car
did you [__] this one so you [__]
this car though I think I did hell yeah
yeah dude we're just trying to be so
straight oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
I think I did but that's cool you bought
your cell phone car five well I mean the
ways you got and weird memes yeah yeah
all your stories are really great but
there's always some debauchery mixed in
between it so I always feel weird about
yourself like oh we're so [__] hard
selling drugs to kids
oh you know what's cool though so uh
when I finally actually turned my life
from and I graduated boot camp my mom
was like really proud of me and so she
bought me my first truck ever oh she
bought it for you and yeah and that was
like my dream truck
2003 silver Tacoma double cab oh that
one yeah I was
and happy that was like
I was like dream cars yeah yeah cool
that was a dream car he added a blue one
no oh no that one the one that was slow
as [__] yeah yeah because then I ended
up lifting it for 35s it was so so Home
Depot special because they only had the
V6 yeah
slowed it down like crazy but when I
went on I went on so many camping trips
like off-road trips I thought it was so
cool dang and it had the off-road tires
already on it and everything so it comes
with 31s I ended up putting 35s on and
that's what made it so slow
um did you ever want to get a a camper
top
[Music]
I remember I was doing so bad in school
because I would never you know just show
up to school at all my dad was like he's
so dumb like he would incentivize me
with [__] I didn't give a [__] about he
was like if you get a good grade so I
buy a BMW I'm like I don't like cars
and I remember like when I graduated he
yelled at me he goes I told you I'd buy
you BMW I'm like he's like get all my
cars
what kind of Korean are you if you don't
like a BMW
that's true I still remember that too
you look like a three series
I buy you a dry cleaner
brand new BMW I pulled you back three
brand new CC's and you still never get a
good grade
I don't care about cars I get you Palmas
oh yeah
that's great because uh yeah for some
reason a bunch of fans wanted us to talk
more about like cars that we've had
we're all into we never talk about [__]
that we're into we're just here dick
dick and fart jokes all day long we
started sort of talking about a little
bit one time and then people were like
yo and I want you to talk about that so
that's cool that you that's a cool thing
for everyone to learn this truck crazy
dude hey but remember when you had a
Jeep Grand Cherokee oh that's right yeah
Jeep Grand Cherokees that's why when you
guys had him on that's a sick car
foreign